[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants
elle est encombrante avaline nounours et
tu ne veut toujours pas me dire ce qu'il
ya dedans
non monsieur mon patron c'est une
surprise et je n'ouvrirai cette valise
cochet pas preneur andy cole à mon les
cheveux ma valise et bien mes petits
amis
il ne nous reste plus qu'à attendre que
nounours louvre et nous saurons enfin ce
qu'elle contient
[Musique]
bonsoir du colloque beau sport propre
non je vous amène un voyageur un gros
voyage hors jeu ne nous affolons pas
tenez bouger ma valise sur la tête
[Applaudissements]
c'est un hommage à nos bases
c'est un monsieur qui n'arrête pas de
voyager et celui ci voyage avec sa
maison qui a une maison de la vanille il
porte même sa maison sur son dos alors
nous ne devinez pas qui sait qu'on peut
être une histoire
et oui allons mettre nos vies jeux
bretons je ne trouve pas plus j'ai dû de
l'est se tromper je trouve pas non
qu'est ce que j'ai fait de cette hausse
que tu es ma la noce pourquoi rien
laquelle nos motos
quand je suis bi temps attention j'ouvre
la voilà qui est ce qu'un grand pirate
écorne sinon je t'ai est ce qu'un beau
tir raté comme la cheville une chanson
jusqu'à ce qu'en voiture atteint comme
du colloque va chercher de la salade
verte pour notre nouvel album
[Musique]
voilà la salade pour monsieur l'escargot
qu'il est content il en a de la chance
de voir sa maison sur son taux de mal
j'ai très pratique pour les voyages
allons petit escargot manger votre
salade
j'ai fait dodo nuit petit escargot bonne
nuit
nomade pour deux nuits dont
oh
inouï comme ça dort jusqu'à 1 go
ils rentrent leur tête dans leur
quotidien ils ferment les yeux et il
dans exactement allons bonne nuit les
petits escargots panel otomo bonne nuit
les enfants n'oubliez pas de faire votre
toilette de bien vous laver les dents
embrasse bien fort vos parents allez
vite vous coucher il fait de beaux rêves
enlevons bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bon soit
pas trop le temps est humide ce soit
notre petit escargot doit être très
content savez vous que les escargots
sorte quand il pleut oh non je ne sauve
pas mais moi je n'aime pas la pluie
je préfère la nar elle me fait un beau
manteau tout blanc ou deschamps a tout
de suite patron du toit qui s'est caché
bonsoir mes petits mais tu sais ton ami
l'escargot je lui apporte une salade
mais elle en a déjà
il est plus là comment ça il est perdu
il s'est caché il ne peut pas aller bien
loin
nous allons le chercher petit escargot
petit minot nounours t'as portes de la
salle à
il n'est pas sur la cheminée
non non j'ai regardé peut-être sous le
dit nous nous tapons de la seule qui ait
pas et perd son beau le coquin il se
cache et regarder dans la salle de bains
dans la baignoire
riez pas dans le lavabo
c'est un film beau temps c'est peut-être
caché dans la salle anne pow d'autres
cherchons man on ne voit pas non plus
tout au moins trois raisons pas pourquoi
elle dit que les escargots et doivent
rester à la campagne n'est pas là et et
non pas là doucement le chant sont jetés
pas bien cela le voilà
je les trouvais medida ils s'en allaient
quittera conteneurs le pauvre petit
il a envie de retourner à la campagne
dans une prairie bien faire
alors qu'est ce qu'on veut tu as mais
nous on ira le voir à la quentin
darqroom allons petit escargot dit
bonsoir à nicolas les appâts brenets
enfin petit escargot avant tout une mode
une nous on va se coucher tout seul que
des grands dont s'honore pas de nuit
denis nicolas meunier pimprenelle quand
pierre
oh
[Musique]
vos nuits les enfants
à te voilà nounours me voilà pas trop
regarder qui joorawon il s'ennuyait le
pauvre petit on leur apporte chez lui
patron excellente idée nounours en route
vers luchon de ce cargo
1 demain les enfants fait pour eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants ne fait pas de bruit
nounours a mal à la tête pauvre nounours
colle mal d'auteurs patron je descends
juste embrassé mes deux petits amis et
je remonte à tout de suite north
molsheim où l'europe ou le pom pom pom
poms poms poms poms poms bonsoir pauvres
petits chéris mais qu'est ce que t'as
gemon j'ai tellement mal à l'automne un
beau petit nous
nous assieds toi vote soigner oui oh mon
nom on en a bien là cette attaque
madame est lui assez sert abonnés pour
sa tête n'est pas bonne pour cet atelier
l'himalaya bas de son dos
mon âme de mon âme bien monsieur et
madame lui a fait faire une peur de le
noble et percu lunettes bleues elles
venaient pour s'attaquer à la bo de soul
de l'eau non non non non non non a bien
mollasson mais à terme il lui a fait
faire de la pommade coffret de la
pommade confrères et des lunettes plus
de fans pour sa tête et delilah l'aveu
de son dos
mon âne de montmagny a bien palace
accord je peux m'amuser faire là bas
tant des produits impactant que scott
d'orge coup de la pommade couvrir les
pertes des lunettes bleues book ou pas
n'est pour sa tête
[Musique]
opium en leçon fonde ademe lui a fait
faire que la dizaine de mètres de là tu
donnes demande
battus lors de leurs deux confrères à la
commande chanteurs présents n'ont pas
encore mal et ma tête je suis guéri les
enfants se sucre d'or est un rebelle
merveilleux pour les maux de tête merci
les petits voilà j'arrive pas trop je me
sauve mais petit veinard ses soins il
doit bien ne vous inquiétez pas je
mangerai tout le sucre d'orge me
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
où
ennuyée enfants mais voilà notre
nounours qui remonte en a une allure
north faute à trop bien mais je n'ai
plus mal à la tête je suis guéri patron
était sous 2000 $ 2010 oroz alan un
route gros gourmand
bah de nuit fuck de pont re bonsoir les
enfants notre petit nuage
on hamm est notoire un grand artiste
nour le gotha patron paul choses
verrouillées
et 3 prend enfin embrun ragona
picasso
l'ours
à vos souhaits m nounours bon le seul
humain jetés sans faire le portrait de
tonia un grenelle la pom pom poms poms
poms poms poms pour propos punch et bois
mulhouse
couvrez mois les enfants je suis très
fatigué bourges le sait les petits de du
débarras chez moi de tout ses
accessoires dans un jeu de valises c'est
ma droite peinture nicolas tu peux
regarder
[Musique]
tu paies je fais de la peinture dans ce
que tu en as des affaires de ma toile
twitter
ouais sur la châsse beau
je veux exécuté ce soir le portrait de
patronne heures ce sera une oeuvre par
nicolas si on voit ça et moi nous nous
qu'est-ce que je tiens toi pas preneur
tu ne bouges pas tu t'assois là tu
regardes vers latins non mon petit on
regarder plutôt de l'autre côté et
surtout ne riez pas mais l'espagne où
nicolas apporter aux roses à votre sort
voilà m
attention je pas mais pas trop vrai la
mecque
sinon j'exécute à toi de jouer
non
hop hop à fond là du rouge
drew cheveux le rouge sera le coup franc
est flat vrai du vertendre du vert gazon
je flat intradel lafleur 3
ça vient je leur en europe
jean découlant
long de la vie d'ailleurs des fermes
sénat
il faut laisser sécher
[Musique]
ce pont n'est ce pas faisant front
oui c'est beau mais c'est pas fini nous
finirons tom je laisse toutes mes
affaires
ne touchez pas on ne touchera pas cbre
amis et on va se coucher tout seul pas
nui no mad men ottoman
mon
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les petits amis patrons ce
que je suis heureux j'ai fait un superbe
portrait de pimprenelle bravo nounours
tu as tous les dons allons en route car
il est tard haute à demain bonne nuit
fait pauvre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants rouges trop haut
à quel jeu avez vous joué aujourd'hui
je parie que vous avez fait de la
peinture pas trop haut je vais finir la
donne se porterait pas preneur soit
rachat d'or je compte sur toi nounours
bon les seuls gros pow pow wow qui voit
là j'suis sûr qui verra pas que son
tableau est à l'envers
bonsoir bugeaud petit entraînement cieux
grands artistes au travail
ne perdons pas de temps
le cpo popeye la fict avait vraiment un
drôle de talent et ma main elle a dit
heureusement que ma fille ait la passe
et est là ne perdons pas de temps
mes pinceaux tu as raison
ne perdons pas de temps ils ont retenu
malheureux avec vous des noës riou fait
de la peinture
ben non c'est amusant rouge et jaune au
batofar gauche ou moioli on se courront
hollow vous au village
ces propos s'ils vont le choc c'est
formidable aventure oui on en fera part
est d'accord dimanche le choc va se
coucher
[Musique]
non
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nos deux petits amis sont bien turbulent
ce soir trop fauchés fauché avec mes
amis je sois mon pauvre nounours nicolas
et pimprenelle ont été très méchant avec
toi ô mon pauvre tableau pas trop
une oeuvre par un j'aurais pu offrir à
la national gallery ne pleure pas nous
nord ce qui en fera d'autres c'est vrai
j'en ferai d'autres
j'ignorais le marché mais je ne ferai
plus le portrait de pape rebelles
je ferai le vôtre pas trop
fait froid votre preuve allons grand
peintre
il est très tard en août
bonne nuit les enfants
allez vite vous coucher et soyez plus
sage que nicolas et pimprenelle et fêtes
de bourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir nos amis notre petit nicolas et
notre petite impro neil sont ils sachent
ce soir aux gens tout autre os et bien
des 100 voire nounours ou non les pas
fort on vit pas trop pourquoi tu ne les
aime plus j'assure que je les joueurs
mais pas quand ils me font de black
qu'au mieux reçois mon petit doigt me
dit qu'ils vont être très gentil avec
toi aujourd'hui
alors j veux mon le seul j'espère qu'il
est plus fâché notre nounou chez moi
vous êtes très gentil avec lui parce
qu'elle aime bien
je ne sais pas si je dois au près
des notes nounours tu sues et je te
prends même on sera sage et ça c'est
pour toi
de violentes muffler bref les rues on
que ce gentil ce qu'elles sont bons
merci le petit assieds toi écoute on a
après une jolie chanson pour toi je vous
écoute les gens font ils étaient une
bonne tartine dans un beau palais de
tokyo
la muraille était de farine le parquet
était de croquer la chambre à coucher de
crème et du lait le lit de biscuits le
rideau de nuit est l'épousé monsieur jal
est coiffée d'un pourquoi mais je plains
son chapeau de galène de son ami était
de nouveau culotte de nougat gillett
chocolat pas de calais
soulié de miel
voici tous les faits n'a pas jalouse et
de mauvaise humeur quand vers celle d'un
coup de sabot le palais sucré du bonheur
pour le bâtir donné à loisir de les
bombes à eau que le joli
vous êtes vraiment de gentils petits
enfants vous savez il ne faut pas manger
trop de sucreries
ce n'est pas bon c'est manos j'apprenais
place cauchy cher
toi voilà j'arrive que ce que se fermer
les yeux et coûter jusqu'à 3 voilà un
deux de trois une grosse us et vous les
petits à jamais des manoeuvres un petit
peu l enfant exemple lé là je t'en veux
te fatigue pas nos sources la jette à la
lumière on a une bonne nuit mon nounours
oh boy nu le musher une bonne nuit et
enfants
ah voici notre nounours
alors tu es content pas trop ce qu'ils
sont millions il manquera que regarder
les belles violer ce qu'elles sont pour
et cette superbe seul et bien dit dont
ils ont été très gentil avec toi ce soir
nos petits amis
connais pas trop ma sucette je vous la
donne
là car moi aussi je montre le bon
exemple
je la mange rue de ben bravo nounours
c'est très bien je te félicite merci
patron n'oubliez pas de me le donner de
mon dieu te le promets
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents allez vite vous coucher
et feu de pauvres
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants
j'espère que vous avez bien manger votre
soupe fait votre toilette et que vous
allez bientôt vous coucher en ont pas
trop long je vais d'abord leur apprendre
une nouvelle chanson ma petite chaîne
qui connaît une nouvelle chanson oui une
très jolie
je vais la prendre à tous mes amis oui
les enfants
je connais une nouvelle chanson
formidable h1n1 d'accord nous reprenons
le refrain ans ont reconnu son talent à
la guerre disait adieu à ses petits
enfants prennent en ça que ça que dans
la poussière elle en a l'air con entre
les éléphants a les crocs rôle et
propres pro les crocodiles sur les bords
du dîner son parti n'en parlons pas
[Musique]
il est parti notamment qu ils agitaient
sa queue dont la poussière comme s'il
était d'avancer triomphant les animaux
devant sabine altière dans la forêt
s'enfuyait tout tremblant le gros coup
de coude et revenir sur mon ordi
notamment à la traque aux crocodiles est
indigne la p1 d'éléphants pas rués sur
la terre se prépare à un combat de
géants mettrait de la cour est une
rivière
le crocodile si je t'assure 8 mans en
les pros crowley crocro les promus
je voulais porter son parti n'en parlons
plus
ah c'est vrai qu'elle est formidable et
cette chanson je la chante tellement
bien vous ne trouvez pas
ah oui c'est vrai et alors les
crocodiles ils ont tourné dans l'audi no
oui les crocodiles sont retournés dans
l'eau et les petits enfants sont allés
comme n'y comprennent rien et n'est
bonne ni musher endormez vous dites là
j'ai tallinn
à 2
demain gros gros gros gros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons en route mon fils est lé nounours
en route
mon sytle pas trop bonne nuit les
enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents allez
vite vous couchez fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
brault soir petit ami j'espère que vous
avez passé une bonne journée et que vous
avez bien manger votre soupe
moi j'ai bon j'ai toute ma soupe pas
trop très bien nous nours tu sais que
lorsqu'on mange bien sa soupe
on devient grand très vite chaussure
patron regardez comme je suis grand et
fort je vais vite voir si nicolas et
pimprenelle ont eux aussi manger leurs
sous on l'échelle prom pompon
bon bon soit vous avez fini de 10 ne
[Musique]
m'arrête là comme johnny color tu que tu
vas devenir grand ça fait grandir
mais bien sûr peuple de baloche à manger
beaucoup
est ce que je vais te crois que nicolas
non tu pourras pas moi c'est pas vrai
nicolas quinault
il est plus petit nicolas at on dit on
va vous me jurez toi pas preneur tu te
veux ici des toits du cola vient
tu te mets contre le dos de passeur et
vous avez leur d'être de la triche
nicolas tuts messieurs les pattes de
pierre alaux et l'eau les pieds à plat
niveau là je crois qu'il faut que tu
manges beaucoup de sous tu es plus petit
pape rhône elle ne sait pas mesurer nos
grands je ne sais pas mesurer
c'est ce que nous allons voir passons de
l'autre côté pas prenait lé même
chercher à m oui allons nicolas mes
toiles n'a appuyé trois voix je m'appuie
viennent nous avait trop boire merci ne
bouge plus nicolas
attention je me joue pas sur la pointe
des pieds nicolau hannon et bien bon pas
l'homme tu mesures à mettre sa
je suis grand je m'appuie et des drèches
bah tu mesures mais disent pas prenez
les plus grandes que toi bien sûr avec
ses cheveux fillol au loin de toute
façon nours elle n'est pas plus grande
que toi au loup et toi combien tu
mesures n'ose remettre à m soit 120 u20
tadieu manger de la soupe
oui je suis grand et fort et ben moi
quand je serai grand je serai grand
comme toi et ben moi aussi bien sûr les
petits surtout si vous mangez bien
allons au dodo moi j'ai quelque chose de
très près ces acheteurs
qu'est ce que tu vas faire tous je veux
savoir combien mesure mon petit patron
willie plus grand toit voyons du col de
bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit des enfants patron patron je
mesure 1 mètre soixante neuf et demi un
mètre soixante neuf et demi
c'est formidable et vous la peine de
vous mesurer
uzak bien plus grand que moi patron
ollo roux bloor ce bonne nuit les
enfants embrasser bien fort votre papa
et votre maman allez vite vous couchez
effet deux fours soyons pas trop chabot
bonsoir les enfants n'ayez pas peur
notre nounours pêche à la ligne et il
s'imagine qu'il va attraper quelque
chose attendue
vous allez voir patron
bah
tu dois te l'ours au genre mais ça non
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce père tu attrapes et dans
le ciel le nours des étoiles ou des
cheminées voulons pas trop de poissons
vau l'eau tu ferais mieux de descendre
voir nicolas et pimprenelle non pas vont
devoir rattraper up aux poissons volants
bon allô allô pimprenelle nicolas c'est
le marchand de sable
nous sommes au dessus de votre maison
mais nounours pêche à la ligne
il viendra plus tard vous avez raison
allez-y qu'est ce qu'ils disent pas trop
rien de nounours rien pas trop j'ai une
touche sa mort ou le la c'est sûrement
une pièce de choix
dutoit tué l'ourse regardez
là c'est un chapeau ou un poisson volant
au chapeau là le nours personnage du
courage noir silence patron olala
qu'elle touche là je faire ce que c'est
vous pour ce one de sardines
c'est incroyable qu'on peut pêcher dans
le ciel est neutre et spa à battre
l'ours courage nounours silence patron
on soit en france ou la victoire la
caisse
elle est tellement grosse que je
n'arrive pas la compter patron vous
voulez bien maintenir solidement la
canne à pêche
[Musique]
merci je m'en vais explorer mon
l'échelle de plongée aux pauvres
nounours
il va être bien attrapés et cette fois
il va être encore au les cocos le copain
je te eux qui me faujas de ben là haut
ils ont accroché une vieille chaussure
un mois ne sont alors on lui petit
garnement trois là
mais chez nous c'est très drôle petit
job ballon d'or vite
et toi aussi pas preneur oui mais plus
juré au bord d'une rivière
vous vous faites dodo là je tends la
lumière bénigne et neuf équipes on
dormait vite les enfants n'oubliez pas
de bien faire votre toilette de vous
laver les dents et le faites de beaux
rêves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mes petits amis au patro mais
oui mon gros nounours descend vite leur
montrer ton beau livre i moi je leur
raconte la suite des aventures de notre
petite amie cornichons
bon le choc oppose aux pompes au les
parents de cornichons n'ont pas encore
retrouvé leur fils et continue à le
chercher partout mais celui-ci ne
s'ennuie pas tu es prêt nounours je suis
propre patron en vous vous pouvez
raconter cornichons habite à présent
chez son ami bûcheron dans la grande
forêt il en a appris des choses qu'il a
appris à siffler comme le merle
oui et à roucouler comme les pigeons
comme sien et à chanter comme le coucou
qui fait coucou chaque matin notre
petite amie se lève très tôt il va se
laver au bord de la rivière isle et
courage et jésus est fou et puis il s'en
va travailler avec son ami le gros
bûcheron couple de grands arbres avec sa
grosse hache et cornichons l'aide de son
mieux mais ce qu'il préfère
c'est de grimper dans les arbres et de
se cacher dans les feuillages cornichons
ou le cul du chevron des chevrons regard
ce que j'ai trouvé
il a découvert tout en haut d'un arbre
honey honey dans lequel se trouve un
petit bout on voit mal un bond de tout
corniche on le prend délicatement et il
descend vite le montrer à son ami ce que
tu le dis le bûcheron cornichons lui
aussi trouve le petit bout très jolie
avec ses grands yeux ronds bûcheron si
nous le gardions avec nous d'accord
répond son ami pour lui faire plaisir
il ramène le petit bout dans leur cabane
en bois tu t'appelles julietta dudit
cornichons nos deux amis se couche
après avoir manger leur soupe et notre
petit corniche on s'endort en pensant à
sa maman son papa et à son ami dada
tandis que juliette a fait sur lui et
tire ses grandes ailes dans les rayons
de la lune
il en a de la veine cette permission il
en fait des choux
oui mais n'a pas encore retrouvé sa
famille je ne t'en veux pas et va leur
trouver cette annonce bien sûr les
enfants
l'histoire est finie ceux qui sont non
[Musique]
on est au lit banier connaissent bonne
nuit les petits la jettent un oeil eu un
tout nouveau
ariane est bonne nuit petit nicolas
bonne nuit petit pape rhône elle
28 tous les enfants allez vite vous
coucher auparavant n'oubliez pas te
faire votre toilette et de pien vous
l'affublent dont il fait de beaux rêves
à demain bono bonsoir je connais des
petits enfants qui vont être très très
content ce soir
nounours leur a apporté une surprise
extraordinaire ce qu'ils votent comptons
patron
il ne faut pas leur dire ce que st on le
cherche
[Musique]
il est arrivé il au top
un chinois nommé nono ne regardait pas
encore c'est une surprise
cachez-vous les yeux et attendait que
j'ai compté jusqu'à 3 1 2 3 c'est un
propos non c'est une graine
oui une grenouille et les vrais ennemis
en salle en onces taddei des sommes
énormes et les rails sans aveu de tout
petit cadeau des dieux
alors vous êtes contents les pépinots et
9 juillet même si nos l'onu mais qu'est
ce qu'elle va manger un peu de farine
est pour grenoux qu'est ce qu'elle va
boire dormir dans son bocal que tu es
bête mais elle est seulement venu vous
dire bonjour
après elle retournera dans sa maison pas
tout de suite non
non donc elle toujours ouais sa maison
au fond d'une geôle image à la campagne
où elle vit avec sa maman et ses amis
grenouille take it can't we do
frappât temps carreau c'est nicolas
comment elle s'appelle cette grenouille
est
je ne sais pas il faut lui trouver un
bon
apprenez à l'eau on a trouvé un immense
lac est comme notre tente ça lui ferait
tellement plaisir ce sont dont elle
était si jolie non résidents elle parle
pas justin non mais lol quoi ce sait
comment ça elle fait croit trop à roue
trois recrues crois ce que tu parles
bien grenouille battu pas mieux qu elle
a encore rien dit parce qu'elle a sauvé
allons on lui dit bonne nuit et on va se
coucher au gros
j'explique aux accords
mais voilà bonne ni les han han
là j'ai un leurre fait deux tours
cette grève nous mais alors nounours
comment se porte cette petite grenouille
justin va très bien patron elle dort
eh bien nous allons faire comme elle ni
les enfants pour une nuit justin à
demain les enfants patron tout envie de
voir justin et mes deux petits james
bond et seul le j-20 important pour
notre nounours est très impatient ce
soir car il veut savoir le temps qu'il
fera demain et vous allez voir que grâce
à notre petite grenouille ont pu
l'apprendre mais on peut aussi se
tromper ça arrive parce que j'ai somain
et pimprenelle moi aussi nicolas au soir
les enfants bros
or christine
comment vous avez déjà sauveur pourquoi
tu nous aux pratiques les grenouilles
saint jean toute la nuit et la chanteuse
toute la nuit et on n'a pas pu dormir
elle a chanté oh tu parles quoi quoi
quoi quoi quoi croit rocroi tu sur wii
merveilleux et elles montaient ou
descendaient leçon de shell
elle montait gzip et fort d'une heure
mais pourquoi n'at mes enfants pour les
grenouilles croise et grimpe à leur
échelle ça veut dire que le lendemain il
fera beau c'est comme ça qu'on fait les
prévisions météorologiques et bien moi
je les plains ceux qui font ça ils
doivent pas dormir souvent bénins
le coin quand tu descends tome échelle
ça veut dire qu'il va pleuvoir
non pas les grenouilles au coi ne nous
laissant son échelle c'est vrai mon dieu
il va pleuvoir
merci quoi elle remonte sur ma chaise
elle est sûre le deuxième par oh c'est
bien juste une
pourquoi que c'est bien cela signifie
une légère hausse de la température
elle est au milieu de l'échelle j'ai
juste une en variable sur la moitié du
cuse elles redescendent une marche
quelques ondées sur les pieds nus on
dirait qu'elle veut sortir du boca aulas
quel changement de temps les enfants qui
comprend plus rien c'est sans doute le
scirocco ce local avec pour une matinale
ça que je suis bon c'est ça temps
variable très bas car voyez comme c'est
facile de faire des prévisions
météorologiques des troupes d'alvin lee
et justin ne chante pas trop cette nuit
[Musique]
il
demain on fera encore des prévisions
météo
oh bien sûr j'ai encore des tas de
choses à vous apprendre c'est là j'étais
lui ne renie pas les grenats noces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un bon conseil ne prenez pas trop au
sérieux
les prévisions de nounours temps
variable patron au puzzle
merci nounours et demain variable patron
très variable et bien en route nounours
bonne nuit les petits faites de beaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir les enfants 11
nous avons eu une de ces tempêtes dans
le ciel j'ai bien cru que nous allions
faire naufrage je vous l'avais annoncé
pas trop temps très variable allons
repasser vous un peu nous avait l'air
d'un beetle comme ça m'a aidé sensible
et petits abbey consultant justin on les
cherche
hop hop hop et ben moi je crois que nous
nous si c'est tromper on soit tu dis que
je me suis trop c'est pas pr neil lennon
a dit que j'estime entente son échelle
quand il va faire beau et ben c'est pas
vrai au fait pourquoi est-ce-que gisti
elle aime beaucoup le lot et la pluie à
la raie manta et maintenant
il va pleuvoir peu sevré et je suis
belle je suis comme ça tu veux dire
il nous faudra encore très mal dans mes
c'est win honoré elle apparaît te parler
le pauvre justin elle s'ennuie
elle veut retourner chez sa maman pas là
bien région paca l'irt et kelly rast
alors justin trop
bon ok
[Musique]
trois co de corpus q qu'est ce qui est
bien connu ce que tu es bavard quand il
parle grenouille
justin est d'accord pour retourner chez
elle mais elle dit qu'elle est triste
car elle vous aime bien et vous avez été
très gentil avec hull auquel à minya
notion te crois tu reviendras nous voir
bientôt comme ça soral temps qu'il fera
allons justin en route
je te ramène chez sa maman pour revoir
les petits allez vite vous coucher enfin
jacky
[Musique]
à demi nicolas un état prenait lé
d'orbiel tu es bien chargé nounours
c'est justin patron elle a envie de
retourner chez eux seuls et bien en
route justin nous ne ramenons dans tamar
bonne nuit les enfants
allez vite vous coucher n'oubliez pas de
vous laver les dons effet de pourrait
[Musique]
sur la terre
cependant je suis bien content d'un
foire et petits-enfants ont le seul
homme je veux pas trop en soir les
enfants notre nounours et bien gai si
nous le faisions une blague
nous allons lui accrocher un ballon dans
le dos
et nounours revient alors aux bascules
l'on tourne le dos là tu as quelque
chose de sale je te l'enlève ne reçut
pas trop vous êtes trop beau voilà ce
n'était rien une poussière là a tout de
suite aux propos propos on va bien
s'amuser des enfants salut le zoo au
chic alors tu nous apporter un ballon
non ne tombons pas si tu nous apporte à
paris vous problème à temps on va de
notre site a pas de bol en la déçoit
nano et regarde oui tu regardes et tu
pars au genou devrait décoller comprenez
par là c'est pas ta tête
cet appel
regarde regarde dans la glace
voyons mais oui j'ai un ballon il me
suis au le voilà encore tomber c'est
formidable
allons les petits au lit je vais montrer
ce phénomène au marchand de sable
or les mystères de la nature
c'est unique ce qui m'arrive
bonne nuit n'ont ni petits belges
restent bien avec nous nos ce bonne nuit
les hauts fonds là j'ai tant que je dis
pas non ce là je tends la lumière demain
tenus nicolas bonnieu prenait lé corps
pierre mais oui c'est notre nounours qui
remonte déjà pas trop pas trop l
aventure c'est extraordinaire qu'y a
t'il d'extraordinaire mon bon nounours
je ballon qui me suit partout où je veux
ras du c'est vrai approche toi un peu
que je te l'enlève
la voilà gros nigo je ne comprends plus
pas trop c'est moi qui l'avait attachée
gros bêta je t'ai fait une blague au
poteau ceux de port sur nous mais je
t'ai bien attraper 28 des enfants
allez vite vous coucher le fait que pour
[Musique]
oh